hotter than the sands of arrakis is the
news that dune part 2 has officially
been greenlit and with that comes a
bunch of new characters that will need
to be cast these include emperor shadom
fade raltha harkonnen alia etredes and
princess ireland so i thought it would
be fun to name my dream picks to fill
out these rules here's your spoiler
warning if you don't want to know what
might happen in part 2 but if you do i
have both my dune 1984 ending explained
and children of doom videos that cover
these stories in much more depth let's
start with notably the biggest absence
from part 1 which is emperor shadom this
was really interesting considering in
the 1984 version he was such a prominent
character but it kind of makes sense
since we don't actually see the emperor
in the flesh until about 700 pages into
the book i actually liked what
villeneuve did here by not showing him
he becomes this ominous presence a man
more powerful and dangerous than baron
vladimir harkinan in fact the baron says
of the emperor that he is a dangerous
jealous man we also know that the
emperor is about 200 years old being
able to reach that age due to the
ingestion of spice according to the 1984
version and this spice longevity allows
for a lot of flexibility in the
emperor's casting i could see anyone
roughly 50 plus playing this role the
first actor actually comes recommended
to me on twitter and i like this
suggestion it's mads mikkelsen he's just
got this unique way about him and oozes
this silent but intimidating energy i
could totally see him being a guy even
the baron would be a little scared of
the second option here is rey finds rey
is no stranger in playing villainous
roles most notably lord voldemort
francis dollar hyde and red dragon and
aemon goth in schindler's list he is the
perfect blend of dangerous and jealous
that baron harkinin described the last
option i want to throw out there is
idris elba historically the emperor has
been portrayed as white but we've seen
villeneuve switch things up especially
with characters like leet kinds so who's
to say the emperor can't be a black man
and i think idris would be a great fit
he's got that strong presence and has
also played the most frightening
character of all time mccavity from cats
moving on in the emperor's family is
princess ireland carino the emperor's
eldest daughter in the 1984 film she was
portrayed by virginia madsen and had
very few lines however casting here will
be extremely important considering how
large of a character she becomes beyond
the original do novel if you've seen my
children of dune video or read the books
you'll know that ireland will become
paul's wife it's a political marriage to
keep the universe from falling into
all-out war in fact in part one paul
even hints at this marriage when he
tells his mom and kinds that he would
marry one of the emperor's daughters to
avoid an all-out war in my opinion
ireland has to be the physical and
emotional opposite of cheney she was
born in a life of opulence raised in the
royal courts and knows nothing of war
and hardship this person has to have a
sense of fragility around them i feel
they should also be a similar age and
stature to timothy chalamet that being
said my first pick would be anya taylor
joy she's arguably one of the most
in-demand actresses currently and she'll
have had experience playing a princess
since she'll be starring alongside chris
pratt in the new mario movie there's
some vulnerability to her which i think
would be a great advantage to the
character another pick serion she just
has this great range to her she can play
a total badass like in 2011's hannah and
also these more down-to-earth characters
with this range i think her and
villeneuve could craft something really
interesting finally i put down florence
pew i thought she was fantastic in
mid-summer and also has a pretty good
range whether it be something more
traditional like little women which
serisha was also in or a badass
operative like in black widow now there
is another character who is very
important but i'm not going to spend a
lot of time discussing or casting
because she's just a kid that's alia
atreides paul's sister in part one we
learned that jessica is pregnant and at
least in the 1984 version the story
advances several years until we see her
about eight years old actually don't
know how old she is here i'm terrible
with guessing ages however even this age
is misleading because the 84 version
says dude or mother's taking of the
water of life while pregnant alia was
born prematurely but grew up at an
extreme pace so when we see alia like
this it's possible she's much younger
than she appears finally another huge
absence from part one fade rautha
harkenan the baron's nephew and brother
to dave batista's rabba who was played
by sting in the 1984 adaptation this
character is kind of like the mirror
image to paul having grown up as a part
of a noble house and trained in various
fighting techniques unlike paul however
he is completely ruthless and the two
have a big one-on-one fight during this
story's climax so whoever we cast here
should be someone roughly the same size
as timothy chalamet may be a bit bigger
we also have to consider that every
harkonnen we've seen in vilnius version
so far has been bald and pale so they
have to be able to pull off that look
this actor should be able to portray
strength with a bit of a thief edgy type
vibe this is someone who doesn't play by
the rules and fights dirty to win one of
the earlier rumored actors to portray
fade was ty sheridan who you may
remember from ready player one i saw
this photo of him and it was like yep i
could see him being fade and taking on
timothy chalamet another actor's name
who i've seen tossed around is harry
styles who proved his acting chops in
2017's dunkirk i could definitely see
him having that villainous edge to him
now this is a bit of a curveball but
could be a fit depending on what
villeneuve is going for asa butterfield
he's got these piercing blue eyes and
this look of innocence that could hide
something truly evil but i want to hear
what actors you feel would be perfect
for these roles in the comments below
thanks for watching everyone make sure
to like and subscribe and for more bad
takes you can follow me on twitter and
instagram at thingstoryt until next time
remember daddy loves you very much